okay so the topic of this pretty short
video here is our sense of smell so
let's go ahead and get started okay so
when we begin with our sense of smell
smell is gonna begin with molecules
drifting around in the air
and these scent molecules that are
drifting around in the air are obviously
then inhaled into our nose so you know
here's a flower something pleasant
well this flower is releasing scent
molecules the scent molecules are
traveling through the air and ultimately
are inhaled into our nose like you see
in our animation well it doesn't have to
be a pleasant odor of course you know
here we have you know armpit odor and so
there are molecules that are floating
around scent molecules from the armpit
that are floating in the air and into
our nose and and now we can smell the
body odor of this particular person you
know as a kid one of my favorite smells
are as the smell of you know fresh-baked
cookies and so the cookies are releasing
scent molecules into the air and again
we inhale them and then we can interpret
that into the smell of the cookies and
one last one of course so you know if
somebody passes gas and and they fart
well the fart scent molecules will be
traveling through the air and can be
inhaled into our nose for our brain to
then interpret well let's go into a
little bit how this works first of all
if we flip over and kind of look at the
underside of our of our nose here our
two nostrils you notice that there are
nose hairs in this person's and nostrils
here the most scent molecules dirt dust
pollen things like this will often get
trapped not just in your nose hair but
also in the sticky mucus membranes
that's inside of our nasal cavity and
these things will then clump together
and this is what we kind of call boogers
and but the whole purpose is to kind of
prevent these things from going deep
into our nose and ultimately it's one
way for us to rid our nose of these dirt
molecules and dust molecules and pollen
grains and scent molecules that often
get trapped so if we kind of now focus
on you know how we might smell the odor
of a flower well first of all we're
gonna inhale some of these scent
molecules through our nostril and in my
animation
they are the scent molecules the purple
colored scent molecules have attached
themselves to what our new are called
chemo receptors at the top of our nose
those the the yellow branches that you
see in the picture there well in our
nose there is mucus and the scent
molecules will dissolve within the mucus
that's inside of our nasal cavity and
what happens and that's like you can see
in the animation the scent molecules
that we inhale from this flower will
attach themselves to chemo receptors
that are in the back of the nose chemo
is a prefix that means chemical so these
chemical receptors have caught and
trapped scent molecules from the flower
what happens next is these scent
molecules will trigger the chemo
receptors to create an action potential
or an impulse an electrical signal and
that electrical signal will travel up
what is called the olfactory nerve and
you can see in the picture the olfactory
nerve leads directly into the brain and
now it's your brains job to interpret
this particular impulse is this an
impulse of a pleasant odor is this an
impulse from a odor which we find
repulsive but that's your brains job to
now determine that
and so there you have a real quick real
quick video on our sense of smell if
you're in my class try to answer these
questions and I'm happy to check your
answers before or after school one day